ha ha here we go again against mr.
Wolverine yeah let's try to avoid to
lose on time we know that you know the
drill is going to be playing quick and I
must avoid the time loss ok maybe not be
too frisky with a bit primos ok what is
he playing know me I think you play some
D 3 stuff and i'm not mistaken no ok I'm
going from one for my AI place d3m I was
still having this in mind yeah this is a
setup that I have firm looked at some
years ago against this it probably
should be refreshed at some point but it
is kind of okay so g6 I can also go to
five now right there should be three as
a somewhat strange move
okay of course give me the space I'll
take it so yeah he's basically has one
idea left this is some F form probably
he will shoot for some f 49 h 4 wide and
4 but I never really expect any of his
moves so I'm not going to try to predict
much him I came so f for him no I mean I
can just go here actually prevent any
night at five and see what happens I
mean if he goes rook fc1 naruki to see
one it doesn't look like he's about to
play a for might still happen and I said
I never expect any office moves like
this one and okay I cannot take this so
nice little tactic but okay I don't mind
to trade dark squared Bishop see anyway
and this is what happens now I guess
mmm so I have to see that I'm played
right on the queenside because this is
where I'm going to win the game if
everything goes some like normally
because black is already pretty clearly
better I think so how to do it just
double on the C file yes that we ignite
on age 60 just a blow in the CFR 85 was
interesting to prevent any before it was
maybe better but I I know that from from
from from earlier games that the main
danger is here to lose on time so let's
not not be too sophisticated him he
tries to play Bishop to g4 yeah that is
something that it will manage i guess
okay i'm going to get the night over to
f7 that was a good plan trading with
bishop d1 Bishop g4 helps why its
position
my idea is to take with the Queen if he
captures and then play Knight f7 so that
I'm save on the King side yeah that
maneuver Bishop d12 g-form probably
helped to arm to equalize the position
for white that that seems ok now ma'am
at least I don't see anything anything
great for me anymore no probably I
needed some kind of improvement I can't
so this f5 now that's not troublesome
one night night to before actually hmm
and I 284 I mean you know I'm taking and
play Quincy 8 this is good in general
the Queen traders welcome anyway as I'm
cougar in attacking his pawns and he's
in taking it with the ticket with the
taking mine um ok 97 let's go them
and see how I can f5 so he's closing
this for whatever reason
well that could be a self-penned on self
penis no good
it's so easy to enter on the queenside
try an f5 now
a5 a4 still difficult to make any
serious headway there cannot do much
ok so let's see doing now with the d3
pawn going back 94 2 f2 oh ok so let me
let me open up the queenside a ticket
queen bee three and i were taking a 3
and d3 and his knights are not doing
much at the moment so i can take and
play Queen B five maybe ok that's not
really attacking it unfortunately but ok
I can capture first and see what happens
now we bring the night over 2f form
that's an idea
and it's five and then i guess going
back to g4 then okay time morning I see
okay but I can I can't play Queenie 69
f5 King h7 and it should work
Jeff I light a fire was unfortunately
pretty good for him check my floor check
and triple check ok seven want to do
that so much let's push this it's just
about stopping this stuff right I'd see
one
how to how to calculate here out for in
2d three two and ice is stopping it
check check
I know I promote where I was a somewhat
scrappy game at the end I'd worth it I'm
dying Jim that I didn't get get enough
out of it yeah somewhere around here I'm
like a strategically clearly better but
I didn't didn't get them get enough out
of it at bishop d 1g4 was pretty good we
are why is black strategically better
I've got more space with the pawn on d4
that said wedge Bishop 1c2 was bad and
his knights are somewhat yeah somewhat
clumsy and on age 6 yeah and the round
here should really win somehow I and I
can win with Bishop 83 okay now I didn't
think about tactics like that that's a
in some way a computer ish movie yeah
you play on the queenside yeah and then
all of a sudden Bishop h3 yeah the thing
is that and if he captures that is
trapped you know this is my black is
clearly better okay now not that was was
not within my abilities and now he gets
Bishop t1n yeah and after that he trades
off his big problem piece and it wasn't
it wasn't bad for him down at all okay
interesting engine wants to do this
probably for night FYI hmm I was
somewhat focused on the idea to put it
on f7 so that I have a good security
there and I don't quite get it my wife
yeah now can win with this okay I can
just win all the pawns so yeah that was
easy yeah I didn't think about H file at
all i played this a bit too passively
actually it's basically
yeah kind of hoping that he wouldn't
would screw up in a slowish position
yeah yeah yeahs again there should be
some kind of some kind of convincing win
but I couldn't couldn't see it night
f-4s actually winning Queen B 2 was
seems to be very annoying him yeah I
wasn't quite sure if he can do something
like that but the engine just goes here
there is no threat whatsoever sorry
gasps it's mostly two nights hanging
them and now the tables have turned I
could have played this one check and win
a pawn you know yeah I screwed that up
very nice position screwed up chan and
then I only had this little idea that
woody for if he goes create now I'm
clearly worse probably losing actually
age six is also an idea I can check
check this is not going to go into help
oh yeah I was Larry lucky she stumbled
into that one champion check yeah I'm
winning I wasn't I wasn't sure really if
that is a win but o naughty one is a win
haha ok and they take you to ok I was
just thinking about pushing the pawns I
know g4 would have won ok I just I just
promote after that yeah okay in this
kind of situation you just have to have
to plan sent and hope for the best yeah
after that it was very easy can still go
here and game continues computer says
I'm winning but this is still has to be
booked has to be a plating with
20 seconds on the clock okay well thanks
for watching